cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
we have this story from Politico
Destroyer Infowars host and colleague of
Alex Jones gets 60 days for January 6
misdemeanor the judge contended that
Shroyer played a role in amping up the
mob at a sensitive moment during the
riot I just want to address that subhead
right away uh Owen Shroyer was not
criminally charged for incitement or
anything pertaining to what other people
did uh oh and I believe you were charged
for just being in restricted area
so do you want to dig into this do you
want to go into the details I want that
to be really clear right away
the judge contended you amped people up
so they're sending you to prison for a
crime you did not commit
a crime they did not charge you with
that's correct I ended up facing one
charge in this
proceeding and that was entering and
remaining on restricted grounds and
without going too into the weeds in this
for obvious reasons
find me one other person
in my situation that's facing those
charges you can't so what am I left to
assume I'm being targeted what else am I
left to assume when I'm the only one
that is having this result
and what's interesting and we can
whenever you want to Tim I mean we can
dig into this sentencing document but
when you go back and we're we're trying
to get the transcription of today's
um Court events to be expedited because
there was no cameras or recordings
allowed in the courtroom so there's a
lot of stuff in there that I think is
going to wow the people so we're trying
to get the transcription of those
proceedings uh published as quickly as
possible because what you find out is
that
the government is trying to have their
cake and eat it too they're trying to
argue that this is not a free speech
case that is their argument that this is
not a free speech case and yet at every
point in their presentation today
their argument was based off of
something that I said there are four
different sections in this sentencing
memo four different Headliners every
single one of them is based off of my
speech now what's also interesting about
this is they have to admit in the
document now they won't say Alex Jones's
name for whatever reason they call them
person well he's so he's person one
person one that's like that should be
his new moniker as like person one he
should just like own that person one but
they admit it they even have a quote in
here try to de-escalate so they quote in
the document that we tried to
de-escalate and then their final
argument is that I tried to amp it up
which one is it but but hold on there
good sir weren't you charged for being
on restricted grounds yes what does
amping up a crowd have to do with being
in the wrong place if a guy steals a
bottle of wine from a liquor store and
then the prosecutor says he once yelled
at a dog I'm gonna be like I young at a
dog's not illegal saying mean words so
dog doesn't has nothing to do with him
stealing wine why is it even a part of a
sentencing document because it's clearly
about your speech who you are what you
do and
you know look I got a photo here NBC
News posted it posted this
says U.S District Court for DC and
there's a a red circle over an
individual that I'm I guess they're
saying it's you right yes uh there's a
whole bunch of other people that are
there including Alex Jones standing
right next to you
are they going to criminally charge Alex
Jones
well I I'd prefer not even to answer
that question but but like
you look at the charges you look at the
sentencing document
it is to uh I would say a reasonable
person concludes when they read to that
document they they highlight your speech
before during and after
oh well hold on there a minute your
speech about politics it's not like you
it's one thing if your speech was yes I
did this thing haha and I'll get away
with it too no no no no it was you on a
show saying the election was stolen and
things like that and they said that was
why you should go to prison
for the charge of being on restricted
grounds completely unrelated if they had
charged you for incitement perhaps that
would have made they didn't because
nothing you said was legal incitement
exactly I should say illegal incitement
and and this is a serious topic and not
to get too campy but the reason why you
joked at the top of the show about if
you're a member of the federal
government you can't tune in tonight is
because the joke is that clearly the
federal government listens to everything
I say and this document is proof
positive and there's even another level
of irony to this
I have been banned off every social
media platform just like Alex Jones we
have to create our own platform at
band.video just so our shows can exist
so and we now know that the federal
government was pursuing these censorship
issues thanks to Elon Musk the Twitter
files the Facebook files and so how
ironic is this the federal government
pushes to have Infowars Alex Jones
myself all censored off the social media
platforms and then they still tune in
every day but here's a question I mean
is is there a I gotta ask a lawyer about
this I was Joe early in the show for
those that are just watching this
segment I said if you uh I hereby revoke
authorization to timcast.com if you are
a federal agent of the government or an
agent of the federal government uh and
if you watch the uncensored show you'll
be in violation of the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act I'm kidding by all means
you are allowed to watch it but I really
wonder about that is there like a legal
way to do that because what you guys do
is you say if uh the authorization for
access to Bandit videos only for
non-governmental employees and if you
are an employee of the federal
government you must subscribe at the at
the one thousand dollar per day level
let's start military
really pay for it to watch you guys yeah
and they're gonna be like well we can't
afford that now they'll do it anyway I
mean of course it's ridiculous they'll
print the money right they'll find out
they'll find out where it comes from
well do you do you know what what's the
deal what are they gonna uh when when
when do they lock you up so there's
still some nuts and bolts to this
there's still some loose ends to this
um if if people want to get a lot of the
information myself and my lawyer had a
press conference outside of the
courthouse today after the proceedings
were finished you can go find that
exclusively at band.video and myself and
my lawyer I mean we we go into it we go
into the weeds we go into the nuts and
bolts
um and so really all the information can
be found there
is like a link or what like is it yeah
if you go to band.video I'm sure you
know I've been running around all day I
haven't gone to check myself but I'm
sure they have it in the front fold or
in the scrolling Marquee so I know it
should be easy to find or at
infowars.com
um but as far as what's next we do plan
to appeal
there's still some questions as far as
I mean we're assuming that we're going
to be able to appeal it'd be it'd be I
mean it'd be like almost as shocking as
the incarceration almost as shocking as
the sentence if they didn't let me
appeal but I mean at this point you know
who knows they may deny the appeal
um and I will also tell you that we
believe that this is an important enough
case to make it to the Supreme Court and
maybe that's where we prefer this case
ends up is that the Supreme Court
because we believe it is that big of a
free speech issue uh for the time being
and my lawyer let the court today know
that we plan to appeal and so at least
for the time being even though I think
the government was kind of biting their
cheek they are going to allow me to not
be incarcerated and remain under my
strict probation during the appeals
process the same probation I've been
under now again
this could all change like the wind
could change directions right and so
when that happens they'll set a date
that I have to turn myself in and and
the rest will uh we'll learn from there
there's still some nuts and bolts I
think that we have to kind of find out
for the rest of the week I'll have more
answers to that if people want to find
my show and I'll keep them updated with
my lawyer at band Out video I host the
war room
um but you know here here's the thing
Tim
there's there's two levels of of me when
I when I look at this and when I think
about this and where it impacts me
obviously the personal level is I don't
want to go to jail I don't believe I
belong in jail
I would even tell you that I believe
that this case should be done and I've
served my probation with good behavior
nonetheless that's not the result that
we got today then there's the other side
of me that's just an American citizen I
remove myself from the picture and it
breaks my heart it breaks my heart that
future Americans may have to suffer
through the same fate or worse it breaks
my heart that somebody a young
journalist coming up or a talk show is
coming up is going to have to censor
themselves chill their free speech or be
afraid that's the thing be afraid of
what they're going to say that's the
thing that people really have have
missed with this whole situation and
again we talked about first order
thinking earlier everyone that's like oh
it's fine they're they're all guilty of
first order thinking because it's not
their political party it's not something
to agree with this is going to be used
against uh first conservatives if the
government gets away with it right so
they first this is the test the small
little see what we can get away with
every time the government success fully
does something that is questionable or
illegal questionably legal or illegal
that only ensures that they're going to
do more later this is not gonna there's
never a time where the government says
oh this is this isn't a new power this
is only in this case they're going to
look at this as oh no now we can go
after people that say that that skirt
the line or whatever there's always
going to be an escalation and this is
going to turn around if conservatives
get into office again this will be used
on the left absolutely I mean and I'm
going to endorse it well it's going to
be used on the left by the left yeah
what what I just just to reference you
know like every Communist Revolution
the first group to be purged is the
revolutionaries yeah because the most
people that die from communism are
communists thankfully right when when uh
we're talking about evil authoritarians
who go around murdering people we need
that we want that to not be the case and
in these revolutions I mean look at
Robespierre live by the sword as it goes
when a revolution happens you now have
factions vying for political power to
have their Vision come true and and the
the meme is there's like a bunch of
people standing around all with the same
thought bubble saying I can't wait for
for the collapse to happen so that my
ideology will take over well what
happens when the system collapses is all
these different groups now say my way no
my way no my way and then someone gets
slightly more political power and says
we've got to take out anybody who
fermented Revolution because there are
only threat the regular people who sit
by and don't do anything they're no
threat to the machine so if these
anti-fall leftists and crack Bots get
their way they're going to be the first
to be locked up in in you know in
federal prisons and kept away from
sunlight and Communications because
they're the real risk to the new to the
new machine well and and you know Monica
you were getting into this earlier and
it goes back to the one train of thought
uh I I don't forgot the phrase that you
used him the one line of thinking here
but you know okay look at some policies
of the left what do they want well they
they want to let's just use the Second
Amendment take they want to disarm
Americans okay so I always ask how many
people have to die
for you to disarm every American how
many people are gonna have to die in
that process and are you going to be
allowed to use guns are you going to be
allowed to use guns to disarm the fellow
Americans and so why does the left seek
power because their policies inherently
need power it is it is a necessity to
have totalitarian control in order to
achieve the Communist Doctrine and so
for all of these people who think they
can go along to get along you know I'm
on their quote-unquote right side right
now they're feeding the alligator hoping
that the alligator eats them last right
and and so we we've seen this throughout
history history repeats itself because
human nature is what it is right but Tim
to your point about how the different
factions then end up cannibalizing each
other right now in the world you've got
three major forces and they're all on
the same side now to knock off the
United States it's America which is the
biggest obstacle to their globalist
plans you've got the globalist Marxist
Revolution you've got the CCP which is a
form of it but unto itself and you've
got the islamists and so all three
factions want to see the end of Western
Civilization certainly the end of
America so they're all working together
now to accomplish that but once they
knock over America assuming that they're
able to accomplish it then they're going
to go up to war with each other and
that's going to be a global
conflagration that you don't want to be
a part of thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time